hey everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today i'm leaving my
webcam off because i am showing you
something
infinitely more exciting uh which is the
xbox series
x in action this is a preview build um
so not necessarily the final product but
i'm going to show you here exactly how
long it takes to get into a game
from me pressing the xbox button on my
controller and then we'll show you some
quick resume titles and um i guess
you'll see a little bit of the ui by
virtue of this but
all right for your reference i'm
pressing the controller in three two
one all right
console is on and
i can see it there we go so i guess my
capture is always going to be a little
bit behind me but
let's jump into ari shall we this is uh
this is a quick regime title and also
one of my games of the year
i think um ari is massively underrated
um seriously this game is absolutely
amazing top to bottom um
but i think that uh it got it did get
hurt a little bit by some performance
problems
where it came out on pc and xbox one but
i feel like almost all of those issues
were totally alleviated by everything
that i've played of the series x version
uh runs a lot smoother here for sure so
worth checking out this game is
beautiful and that's how quickly you get
into it
um absolutely insane close it go home
let's do crackdown
i don't remember if i had crackdown
launched i think i might have quit out
of it so
this should go through the whole loading
process rather than quick as you might
think yeah it will
but still gives you an idea of how fast
this is where
basically the initial loading screen is
actually that that initial
where it says crackdown we're already
into the splash screens here
um seeing these is not loading
um in theory
and as soon as i get a button prompt
i can play the game that's me
solo campaign we could jump into it
right from here
yeah i didn't play a ton of this game
it was like maybe a couple of hours at
most but now that i have the series x i
think i'm going to
um i'm into it
doesn't stand out to me in the same way
that uh ari does
still a good time
here we go we are in crackdown 3
and the cool part is if i just want to
go straight back to ari
this is how fast it is basically to jump
between
two different games done
that quick i think it's cool as hell
oh man i forgot like all the controls
and ari but
so i was like what's his hammer that's a
this game's so good anyway okay let's
show you something else shall we um
i believe grounded doesn't have quick
resume just yet
because it's still in game preview oh i
do have state of decay 2 though we can
do this
this one's cricket regime because i had
already loaded it in as well had already
played it
oh it crashed that's unfortunate try
again
but you know i'm not going to edit that
out let you guys see it again it is
still preview built
things are being updated all the time
the console is absolutely not out yet
but
definitely worth showing you guys that
stuff for sure
that is uh maybe the third time
that something has either done that or
there was one time where i tried to load
a game
and it uh was just a black screen so
uh yeah as i've played more over the
last couple of weeks oh it needs an
update well that's why it happened
that makes more sense okay let's do
let's do halo
actually i think halo might not be
compatible
oh hang on sorry let's go back here and
then go to halo from here
yeah i thought so um halo is not yet
backwards compatible that is a thing
that they are constantly updating which
is also strange
because neither is gears 5. seems like
two games you would have be compatible
but they aren't just yet
um forza isn't either we can
load up fable anniversary
which i think looks oh
this crashes across the board here wow
well hey i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna re-film this video um
because of these issues because i feel
like you guys should see them but i will
also say
this is uh an unusual situation
not not what is reflective of most of my
experience
but i think that's why in part i'm very
glad they sent out preview units this
early because
you know you can play around with this
stuff have enough time
to have a a day where a few things
didn't open
it's important i do love smart class but
i'm gonna pass in this instance thank
you
so i love this game anyone who knows me
probably already knows that
but i do want to mention it um even on
the xbox one x
can take forever to load
and also it's frequently choppy in the
menu um
pretty choppy in the map which already
feels a lot smoother than it was
previously this game definitely launched
with a lot of bugs is basically what i'm
saying
and that is literally the extent of the
loading if i were to guess i would think
fable anniversary load times have been
cut
by three quarters it is that much faster
um super impressed with the speed of
these
of these load times and then again quick
resume i can still just start that up
absolutely whenever i want to so
hey
think this is the duty wants the
mushrooms
yeah you trying to get high out here
okay let's jump back out
and i can launch uh i think
i can launch a plague tree i can launch
control which i've also not played on
this unit
i played control on pc and then
sort of jumping back into it more
recently on the series x because i want
to get
up to date for that allen wake expansion
but yeah i guess you got to keep in mind
how long things take to load for you
rather than uh
then just for me here but i will launch
this and then we will jump back to quick
regime and jump between the three games
and see how fast we can do it if the
ones we have currently up are alrea
crack down and control
continue
this game can also take a really long
time to load that's for sure
here we go you're in control
all right i'm just gonna
straight up swap it down back to ari
it's that fast let's go fable
a bit of a starter there
immediately in a quest ah you gotta tap
that a button
and then yeah i mean
again the only other that's i mean still
downloading i don't think download
speeds have changed at all obviously
the only other game that i can uh launch
for you guys
is crackdown right now but it's quick
regime as well
basically meaning that right now i have
four games running simultaneously that i
can uh swap between
there it is they just stay on pause and
then you jump back in
you on pause and you're playing a video
game
i feel like i chose like accidentally
sort of three games where you can kind
of fly
and then fable where you're just
chilling so that's pretty much it you
guys that's all i'm allowed to show you
right now um i did put up a video asking
you guys for questions
i will be allowed to answer those soon
but there's a lot of stuff that is still
under embargo
um but this is basically how quick
regime functions how quick things
load and of course you guys did see a
couple of little errors in here
um which is which is gonna happen in a
preview build
i'm not gonna remove those for the sake
of the video
um but do again want to reiterate not
common these are not things that are
happening to me all the time so worth
noting
but um yeah that's pretty much it this
is
how the xbox series x runs um
i i am very impressed
thanks for watching everyone let me know
if you have any questions for that video
as well you can add them here or to my
other video asking for questions i don't
mind
either option is cool with me uh hope
you're all having a good weekend
bye